aujourd'hui, nous travaillions sur des coups de pied et des
techniques et ces choses comme des
trucs et des tours et des trucs tous les jours
il y a quelque chose qui est plus facile et
quelque chose qui est plus difficile, nous voulions
trouver un style qui semble différent de
la façon dont vous voyez la plupart des femmes se battre
et filmer en général  Je dirais qu'elle se
bat comme un garçon, sauf que cela diminue
le fait qu'elle se bat juste comme une
femme vraiment très forte. Tess s'est
jetée là-
dessus de la manière la plus extraordinaire, un
engagement incroyable envers le physique est de la
part de la minute où vous ouvrez le  porte Wow
quelqu'un a une histoire Tessa était si
convaincante et puissante et mystérieuse
que nous avons tellement parlé à Hollywood de la
représentation des femmes et nous avons besoin de
pièces de rechange très fortes pour les femmes,
mais nous avons aussi besoin de femmes qui sont en
conflit et qui ne sont pas si géniales que
nous  besoin d'une représentation à tous
les niveaux